hey guys wanting to create another short
video on breastfeeding someone had a
question that wanted to know how
important is it to breastfeed versus can
I just give my infant infant formula
okay so I really wanted to talk about
this really important point that
breastfeeding is so crucial in
determining a child's health because
breastfeeding can significantly protect
a child against weight problems obesity
diabetes metabolic syndrome which is
high blood pressure high cholesterol
asthma allergies and the future of the
child's health really starts with what
you initially feed the child with the
microbes in the colon are so much
different when fed breasts breast milk
versus infant formula the the infant
formulas are just so filled with
synthetic vitamins corn syrup soy
products that they actually increase
insulin levels and insulin is behind so
many health problems so you want to
breastfeed for minimally six months but
preferably up to two years or a little
bit longer all right thanks for watching
so I hope you're coming to the keto
Health Summit coming up in October so I
want to quickly comment on what we're
gonna do that's different from other
conventions okay the problem with these
other conventions is they give you
information over a load okay it's so
much data that you're basically swimming
in a sea of information we're going to
do things very differently we're only
going to cover the most important things
that make a huge difference now there
are three very powerful strategies that
we're going to be talking about at the
summit that you will not find and any of
my youtube videos number one is on
memory I'm going to be showing you
something very cool to dramatically
increase your memory and concentration
that's going to blow you away and number
two I'm going to show you how to
increase your stress tolerance so you
are completely calm all the time alright
and number three and most importantly if
you have a slow metabolism if you've
dyed it for a long time and everything
is kind of just really
I'm gonna show you how to get complete
control over your metabolism so you can
literally turn up the dial as high as
you want and control as much weight as
you want to lose and these three things
are just a tiny bit of what you're going
to learn in the summit so click the link
below get signed up and I will see you
in October